>> Martha: HAVE AMERICANS BECOME
TOO COMFORTABLE FROM WORKING AT
HOME?
FOUR MILLION AMERICANS QUIT
THEIR JOBS IN APRIL.
AND NOW SOME BOSSES ARE
BEGINNING TO SIGNAL THAT COUCH
TIME IS OVER.
>> IF YOU CAN GO TO ARRES
REST
IN NEW YORK CITY, YOU CAN COME
TO WORK.
LABOR DAY IF PEOPLE DON'T FIND
THEIR WAY IN, WE'LL HAVE A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
>> Martha: JOINING ME NOW,
KAYLEIGH McENANY , FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
LOVE HAVING YOU HERE WHEN YOU'RE
ABLE TO COME BY.
YOU HAD A BUSY DAY.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK A
LOT ABOUT.
THIS MESSAGE, RIGHT?
THIS BOSS HAD THE GUTS TO SAY
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE GUTS TO SAY, YOU'RE GOING TO
THE RESTAURANT, YOU'RE GOING TO
THE GROCERY STORE, YOU CAN SHOW
UP IN THE WORKPLACE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S JUST LIKE THE TAIL WIND
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT BEHIND
OUR COUNTRY WHEN HE STOOD AT THE
PODIUM AND THE SCIENCE SAYS GO
BACK TO SCHOOL, OPEN OUR
CHANGE-UPS.
THEY'RE FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE.
THERE'S A NECESSARY ADVOCACY
THAT SHOULD FOLLOW THAT IT'S
TIME TO GO BACK TO WORK.
IT'S HEALTHY TO GET OFF OF ZOOM
AND HAVE YOUR ADULT MEETINGS AND
INTERACTIONS.
>> Martha: EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
IT BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR.
THE STRUCTURE THAT USED TO EXIST
THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE TO GO TO
WORK, TO GO TO THE OFFICE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT HEARING
ENOUGH ABOUT FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE AT THIS POINT.
I WONDER WITH THE VACCINATIONS
SO UNDERWAY, WHICH HAS BEEN AN
ENORMOUS SUCCESS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD SAY?
WOULD HE AGREE WITH THIS CEO AND
HOW HARD WOULD HE PUSH TO TELL
COMPANIES TO GET BACK?
>> THERE'S NO DENYING THAT HE
WOULD BE AT THE PODIUM.
ECHOING WHAT YOU HEARD.
BY THE WAY, LET ME EMPHASIZE THE
MORGAN STANLEY CEO IS
COMPASSIONATE.
HE WAS COMPASSIONATE BUT THE
SAME TIME HE RECOGNIZES THAT 90%
OF HIS COMPANY HAS BEEN
VACCINATED, COMING BACK TO WORK.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, A HUGE
DISPARITY IN TEXAS WHERE 50% OF
THE PEOPLE ARE BACK TO WORK
VERSUS NEW YORK AND
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE IT'S 21%.
THAT IS FEAR OF COVID.
THAT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
SAY TO THE MORE LIBERAL CITIES,
YOU CAN FEEL SAFE.
>> Martha: IS IT REAL FEAR OR
NOT?
HE'S SAYING ARE YOU GOING OUT
FOR DINNER?
ARE YOU GOING TO THE GROCERY
STORE?
WHY -- IF YOU'RE DOING THOSE
THINGS, IF YOU'RE TERRIFIED IN
YOUR APARTMENT, THAT'S ANOTHER
ISSUE.
WHATEVER.
IF YOU'RE DOING THESE THINGS --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT COMPETITION
WITH CHINA, FOR EXAMPLE.
CAN WE -- WHAT HAPPENS TO
GROWTH?
WHAT HAPPENS TO OUR NATION IF WE
DON'T COPIED AT THAT LEVEL?
I DON'T THINK THAT OTHER
COUNTRIES, CHINA IN PARTICULAR,
WILL BE OPERATING FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
>> WE HAVE TO COMPETE AT THAT
LEVEL.
158 CASES OF COVID, WE GOT TO
COMPETE WITH CHINA TO YOUR POINT
THAT MEANS SHOWING UP FOR WORK,
GETTING BACK TO LIFE AS USUAL
AND RELYING ON THE SCIENCE THAT
WE'RE VACCINATED AND WE CAN HAVE
THIS INTERACTION.
>> IT'S ECONOMIC COMPETITION
WILL BE BECOME MORE AND MORE
STIFF AS THIS FALLS TO THE
WAYSIDE, THANK GOD.
THAT DOE